Please welcome Patricia Arquette.
(audience applauding)
(melodic upbeat music)
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Hi.
So happy to see you.
Good to see you, girl.
(audience applauding)
And now I've gotta get back up.
(both laughing)
(audience applauding)
You look beautiful, girl.
Okay, I remember you driving through West Hollywood
with your son in the backseat in his car seat
in a Suzuki Samurai.
That's right, people, okay. (laughing)
And you looked so cool.
Aw.
In your like open air.
Oh, my first car I bought myself.
And I used to see you driving around
and every time I saw you, I was like, "There she is."
(Patricia laughing)
And if it's okay,
could I play what is one of my favorite games
here on this show with you?
Yes, play it.
Alright, everybody,
we're gonna play with Patricia Arquette Behind the Scenes.
(audience applauding)
(melodic orchestral music)
Alright, "True Romance."
Yes, okay, Behind the Scenes.
(audience cheering)
Here's a crazy story, so Tony Scott, our director,
I came in with hair like that, right.
He's like, "I do not like that hair."
I was like, "But I really wanna have this hair."
And he was like, "Okay, why are you doing that hair?"
And I was like, "Well, I think she grew up
watching Farrah Fawcett
and she doesn't know how to do feathered hair,
but this is her like version of feathered hair.
He's like, "You got it, we're wearing the rolls.
Okay, (laughs) let's go."
That is the best fly on the wall,
thank gosh for Tony Scott going with your artistic vision.
Yeah.
It pays off in dividends.
Ah.
Beautiful, muah, muah, muah!
(audience applauding)
'Cause that's so cool.
Okay, "Medium."
(audience applauding)
"Medium," yeah.
(audience cheering)
We're working on this show,
we have to do, it's like 16 hour days.
I can't tell you how many times they were like,
"And action," and I'm like, (snoring)
they're like, "Patricia, wake up."
(laughing) Okay.
Did you actually fall asleep?
All the time, I was falling asleep all the time,
when I'm supposed to wake up,
there are times where I'm really waking up. (laughing)
That is so great, I love that
and by the way, good acting, because it's real.
Thank you, exactly, exactly.
(audience applauding)
Okay, "Boyhood," just "Boyhood,"
that's "Boyhood."
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
"Boyhood," another amazing experience.
Richard Linklater, this whole crew, we showed up every year.
It's miraculous that movie ever got financing,
because we could have just in year eight
said like, "Give me a lot more money.
I'm not coming back, whatever."
So when you're winning the Oscar for that film,
are you like, "Oh," not that the experience wasn't enough,
but what's going through your mind,
'cause your speech made headlines
and was magnanimous about equal pay for women.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, yeah.
Well, when I was getting there,
I was like, "Wait, why am I winning this?
If I'm gonna win this, why am I winning this?"
Oh, because I played a mom,
who was the primary caretaker for her kids.
How would her life have been different
had she earned her full dollar
and been able to take care of her kids?
How would their lives have been different?"
So if this moment is gonna happen,
that I didn't try to force to happen,
then I'm gonna use this to do something good for everybody.
So I just went up there and was like, "Okay, here we go."
You know, equal pay and equal rights.
Well, it really made waves around the world
for all the right reasons, thank you.
(audience applauding)
I'm gonna go into next "The Act," oh my God!
Yeah, scary, yeah, poopy.
That's kind of the worst nightmare, right?
And my kids already knew of the story,
I was like, "Hey, I got offered this script, you guys.
It's about Dee Dee and Gypsy Blanchard."
"Don't do it, please don't do it.
Don't do it, Mom, don't do it." (laughing)
I'm like, "You guys, I'm not gonna become her,
come on, you know me."
"Please don't do it, she's so scary."
She's so scary!
Yeah, okay, this one is honestly,
(audience laughing)
It's a beautiful independent film directed by Sean Penn,
it's called "The Indian Runner."
(audience applauding)
When I saw this film,
I thought it was one of the most beautiful performances
I've ever seen from any actress who ever lived.
Aw, thank you.
And there's a moment when Viggo Mortensen,
I think he spits on you.
Yeah.
And your cry, your reaction.
Oh, thank you.
What was filming that scene like?
Oh, it was really intense.
Viggo was great and Sean was great.
Viggo of course felt bad, you know, doing this scene,
but I was like, "No, no, no, let's do this scene."
Let's really go for it and tell the truth of these moments,
you know, that are shocking
and totally disarming.
If you're with somebody you love
and they have impulse control issues and go off on you
and then how do you deal with the ramification
of that kind of storm?
It is so amazing to hear your process.
I feel like I'm getting an "Inside the Actor's Studio,"
Oh, you're so sweet, aw!
like fantasy,
like I'm living in the center of it,
like I'm actually, like I am the fly on the wall.
(melodic upbeat music)